because why is creative commons and dane
date so important to you with the cosmic
i think it's for different reasons which
one of them the end date is important
because i think something very basic
change on the movie industry the you
know before the internet it was the
producers and exhibitors and
distributors who decided when you were
going to watch film you know it was like
okay now you can watch a movie theater
and you need to wait like six months and
then you can buy the DVD and then you
can no you can't wait for another pretty
cute six to eight months and then you
are going to be able to watch on TV and
I think that's absurd it's like if you
go to either not any given shop and you
try to buy a lolly machine and you have
the money in your pan and you say that I
warm that one and he says to you you
know what you come by it sorry you can
come again in a month it's stupid I mean
it's like you're gonna lose money and I
don't understand why like that that
happened with film it's like even if you
want to pay for it you don't you come
sometimes so if you have an alternative
which is the Internet where the films
are for free and available from the
first day of course people scan a pirate
films of course they're going to go to
watch them at home because they don't
want to go to movies or whatever so you
know I think we need to start thinking
in a different way and offer them the
films that way they won't watch them
which is you know when they want where
they want and how they want so that's
the basic reason for day and date for us
and with Creative Commons again you know
it's about sharing it's about using
people not using that sounds bad but you
know using people to promote your film
to you know to give them something they
can share with their friends and this is
the natural way we behave with
everything's like if you like something
you share with your friends and you
invite them and it's like you know all
that things we make in a natural way
with with all the things that are not
film why are we doing them with film and
we try to you know build a monitoring
model is based on different things and I
guess if we
give people what they will at some point
they're gonna you know there's going to
be a return they're going to want to pay
back at some point so you keep making
films for them to towards the way they
like so creative comes about everything
you know about all that about sharing
about being able to just screen the film
with you if you feel like it or even
remix it if you are inspired by it
you